ça tourne ça tourne super aujourd'hui
dans votre Calendrier de l'Avent 100 %
éelinois on parle
bière pour la première je vous emmène à
bois d'Ary la brasserie au cloc vous
propose une cinquantaine de bières
différentes allant de la plus douce à la
plus corsée je prends des bougies je
sais pas pourquoi au cloc c'est
l'histoire de trois amis qui ont décidé
de se lancer dans la bière pose les
bougies ma préférée c'est la side effect
c'est une triple forte en Malte avec des
notes de caramel vous m'en direz des
nouvelles pour la deuxième elle porte
bien son nom on va prendre la petite
sœur c'est une brasserie à Sartrouville
vous pouvez y retrouver tous les
classiques blonde rousse brune mais
aussi des bières de saison comme Noël
par exemple la bière de Noël ça c'était
de l'impro ça et pour finir on a la
district à mole avec une grande variété
de bièrees à commander en ligne ou à
venir chercher en drive je vais
m'asseoir là toutes les bières sont
disponibles à un prix moyen de 3 € plus
que de la bière une ambiance yvelinoise
à glisser sous le sapin en rapport au
sapin que j'ai audessus de moi et bien
entendu à consommer avec modération
bonne fête et je crois que je suis je
suis fait pour ça en fait là